Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That number
is two one nine two. David P. Here is
one of my favorite voicemail types,
and it is when someone tells me I should really
go to communist countries if I love them so much,
ignoring the fact that I have no interest in
communism or communist countries. Take a listen.
Speaker 6: I just heard your comments on the
Trump rally, right? I think you really need to try
try something like a special exercise, you know,
like a knee squat reach far back because you can,
with both hands, try to hold on to your ears or
could find your ears and hold on to them and pull
your head out of your rear end.
Speaker 1: I'm having trouble
picturing this, but let's continue.
Speaker 6: You're obviously one of those
liberals that's got tendencies and gay tendencies.
Speaker 1: It's like, what? What does what
does that even have to do with anything? It's
always anti-Semitic or homophobic at its core,
very un-American.
Speaker 6: Go to a communist country
and live there. See how you like it there.
Speaker 1: This is so funny because as many
of you know, much of my audience
hates that I'm not a communist,
but I'm not a communist. I'm not interested in
communist countries. Stalinist Leninism is not
something. I'm a fan of Chavez, Maduro, I'm not
a fan, you know? However, you wanted to define
the ideal socialist or communist kind of whatever.
That's not me. Find someone else. I'm not
interested in that. I'm interested in a capitalist
northern European democracies. I'm interested.
Yeah. Come on, guys. Give me a break. But as
usual, somewhere in there is some homophobia.
In this case. Sometimes it's anti-Semitism. We've
got a great bonus show for you. Today we'll talk
about the Neil Young Joe Rogan Spotify debacle.
We will talk about the heart transplant denial
due to no COVID vaccine that many of you have
written to me about. And much more all of those
stories on today's opponents show. Sign
up at Join Patricof to get into Doctor.